you
starting any second less than 30 okay
here we go oh why did it jump away
double those points it just jumped away
from me warzone Kings we're going to
enter now a Benoni let's go let's go
crazy with the banana here what my
opponent isn't moving okay they're
moving Oh
okay so maybe actually there's some
stuff I could still be getting over over
we're over against f2 I'm gonna give up
the dark square Bishop I want to go
after that dark squared Bishop let's
let's try for this okay there's no
tactics really I don't think that they
are working it's take here and then I
have to keep an eye on this pond I want
to secure my bishops position my
light-square bishop working castle on
this side it's I think safer f6 I need
to get rid of this support point this
and I could jump in here my rook working
give this check jump my knight in here
take like this I could drop my Queen
back I'm also on their Knight twice I'm
dropping dropping h6 but I have this
right here I have to be very calm on
this square oh I dropped they drop their
Queen under rook and Bishop I think
their King has to move up to defend now
they're rookies in a pin oh my king up
okay and give some checks looking to
pick off one of the rooks because they
are not connected Queen here in
particular I can't go there let's get my
rook activated rook back here I have
that move just get rid of one of them
okay now this is maybe mate very soon Oh
it's time how much time not a lot not a
lot of time 0.1 know they had point one
I had five point one what a tough game
to start it jumped over it
it jumped over a tab when the tournament
began all right I have two points to
begin and I really want to push this
night around so let me do that for
starters right here I think I just
developed a c4 not worry about doubled
pawns it reinforces my Center and maybe
I could get some play in the B file I'm
looking for me on f2 I could support it
also I'm in this pin but I could get out
of it with this advance their Knight is
kind of stuck we get rid of the dark
square Bishop and look for me getting
getting my queen on this diagonal I'll
kick this clean away I'm on the Queen
right now Queen takes pawn Bishop takes
Bishop Queen here and then rook up and
over stuff oh they're gonna take my
bishop right now I should have taken
here and then done this idea of h3 g4
okay I guess we're gonna have the
Queen's come off this Bishop is kind of
stuck though I don't really like that I
don't like that at all night here okay
take that and then I could do this wolf
okay now a very strong connected passed
pawn no way I don't want to give up that
d-file King is gonna play here yeah
Kings very active and now well then we
can't go too far he has to watch over
that I'm that passed pawn okay my king
here I want to be able to do this rook
move I don't even know what that move is
doing okay they're gonna run out of
moves aren't they okay jump over here
actually I need to get my King working
let's try this again I have a plan I
promise I promise I have a plan my King
needs to do something over here he's the
one that wants to attack those black
pawns I can't go anywhere I can take
this take this pawn come right back over
here
they're down on time doesn't matter back
to turn I was trying to win objectively
that was stupid he's that clock to your
advantage use that clock to your
advantage when I time or position
this guy's gonna play c4 it's their
fourth time I'm playing him I think last
time I think it turned out like this
since the similar variation where I get
b5 in and I end up winning their Bishop
last time we played their Knight moved
here and I got there bishop not
happening this time though my Knights
are protected shift on this move now
this one the seniors a little bit better
they still can't do this advance now
this is a great home and now I'm winning
this pawn I'm on their queen then I
could move I got there bishop again but
they get a piece back let's drop all the
way back I'm just gonna take where I got
to watch out for a night here to here
it's a little too scary get him out of
there before it's too late
Oh put my queen in the line of fire
there huh not a good idea
definitely not a good idea let me put my
opponent in a pin and get my Bishop on
c6 their knight is stuck the knight
can't move
now their Knight is unprotected hitting
again and now that rook is falling with
check and after you take here the Queen
is hit she can't go too far away she
can't go too far away I'm looking for
the tactic of deflection I'll go for
this even though giving up the two rooks
I had that flight Square and I have the
Queen actually and this should be GG 10
seconds they resigned back to tournament
twenty twelve twelve twelve this is the
guy that was up there last time that a
pawn Center me you know second or third
and that the cute fanatics quick
resigner whoo and have any of those in a
long while 2016 Patriot chests Tom Brady
right now mr. Tom Brady I have to play
against okay
it's a silly land okay let's get my
pieces working all right
my dark square Bishop wants to be where
it's in do some darks for our weaknesses
I want to get rid of there oh that's an
important pond Oh Queens gun just like
that she is gone
rid of the darks rubbish and the Terr my
knight on f4 I'll be made very soon
Queen here is also available picking off
the night I'll go after the night so
he's gone I think I almost missed Mouse
lip there Queen c4 they resigned back to
chairman thirty twenty six twenty
eighteen twenty three minutes remaining
twenty three minutes 23 seconds tried d4
okay some type of Benoni and let's get
my Bishop on this diagonal soon I'm
anticipating they are going to fin you
kiddo and that's fine cut out the other
one keep this move and stop stop that
from happening this night move in here
I'm alright with this I think I don't
want to allow that on I just don't want
to allow that to happen that pawn wall
the a5 f e5 f5 f5 structure I'm gonna
take here as an in-between shot and then
here and then get my knight here
tonight's gonna post up on this square
it's actually get rid of them and now
I'm gonna want to look to play against
this pawn that's why the recapturing
it's our queen recapturing at the bishop
I could have taken here I actually
wasn't I did I wasn't gonna do that
although it would have been best now
there's pressure on this pond and I'm
gonna give it check no I mean this this
is this not gonna be kicked away and
then this pawn gonna be won whoa
let's um let's do this that's two fifths
oh I'm in check
I knew that didn't I oh my goodness
now I could defend this my knight is a
very good
Kerrigan's cool checks actually not just
my night up every night it's every night
is very good at giving Forks and also
blocking against Queen checks when she's
close to the king that's a that's still
check that's still check right
rookies may be dead soon they're gonna
resign their Donna time 38 38 30 28 2004
t 242 oh that's the mouse mouse slipped
Sicilian variation who knows about that
okay so we're entering an endgame now or
I get to do my favorite thing Queen
trade or I get to say no my opponent
will not Castle kingside or will they
all right let's just take it now and
secure my Queens my Knights position on
f5 this is going to be a long game a
long strategic game I want my king to
take up residence on f7 believe it or
not so I'm gonna play this which boxes
out the knight from jumping in I've even
seen this in some middle game positions
this it's tough to get at the king with
this knight on f5 a very strong post for
this Knight can't be kicked away that's
why I was doing these h5h four moves and
I'm clamping down on this structure as
well so I'm gonna look for a rook up and
over get my bishop working they're gonna
do a pawn push and now I have to babysit
this pawn here which I'm not really a
great fan of so let's do it like this
now the c6 pound is likely going to be
the target so I want to get in c5 let me
do this this pond is gonna become past
though let me just make a nothing move
okay let's take care oh I should take it
a rook I should've taken that rook pawn
push I have to back up
to e7 it's no no no I'm on a guard
against my background 12 seconds where's
my time where did it go I'm gonna be in
a pen chop my knight in where time is
the biggest issue okay I'm a knight I
have a fork wow that's close to me no no
over here again a g2 can they move and
attack my rep yes they could no they
resigned didn't make me sweat that one
out then 56 54 52 this guy played in the
first round right all right
Grand Prix I did this in them and the
war zone well I'll just take with this
drop back night here is that gonna be
annoying they gotta have to play Queen
here to still watch over this is a c2
point I get that night out of there what
a pain huh okay he's hit twice defending
once something has to be done I could
hit him a third time as well rook d1 on
my opposite their queen
let's get this night out there actually
if he goes back here then I could take
the knight but I'm not going to I like
my darts for a bishop let's not allow
why let's just open this down open this
up this on open it up word use a thorn
open up this diagonal my light square
Bishop is very strong now the king is
caught in the middle
so my rooks are now gonna play in the
center get both of them in the center I
should have taken this pawn to move
sooner take with my queen it seems
unnatural but I think it's best okay
hopefully a knight can't get here
actually their knight is pinned which
means I could do this move and then
let's do this Bishop here and then pawn
push I think actually works bishop here
and then pawn push with the discovered
trick oh that's tricky if I took with
the night that good to take my queen
I'll just take like that that's check I
want I'm not their night out they're out
I have to be careful of back rank mates
him working I had my rook there to watch
over and I got there clean another queen
is here
okay matin - no matter what all right
back to tournament sixty seventy eight
or 70 68 56 okay why did I go with the
French because because it's the most
aggressive opening out there okay let's
break down this structure let's get my
night working both nights working some
structural damage let's get him out of
there and then pinpoint c3 that is the
plan
pinpoint c3 if the LightSquared bishop
SAR exchanged my night increases in
value okay I have the bishop pair my
Bishop is quite strong like I should
have taken here ah I missed that move
they could just take with the bishop I
just lost a ton of material I'm losing
everything no no everything is hit
everything is hit why didn't I do why
did I do that
ah could I pounced on over here oh I'm
dead just like that this is so busted
this is way busted we're gonna have
Queen trades and everything Queen trades
and everything this is a dead game I
should probably just be resigning this
is gonna hurt it's gonna hurt
can I get made somehow back rank mate no
no way the rookie give check now that's
not really working either oh they have
that covered they have that covered I'm
just gonna give a check Oh
hit that resign button down 88 7000 up
takes Bishop that's what that Bishop
backing up move did oh I gotta recover I
lost the whole farm on that one I lost
the whole farm I thought I would be able
to get the exchange not the case not the
case all right I gotta go four quick
kills I have to do stuff that is
objectively bad but practically good
somehow
and that means launching aged funds age
five I feel like I just want to
sacrifice on each five get both nights
in there get both tonight's in their
night here to hear some kind of crazy
tricks some kind take like this I want
to get on this diagonal I think my pond
is gonna be hit okay I have this covered
my knight could do some damage or no he
could he could watch over the beef I'll
pressure with Knight d5 there's pressure
along the files my other night in here
look for made on f6 the pond has to push
I should have made very soon actually
well the Knights there to block now he
has to go there Knight f6 and then I try
to open up the F file
it's a matin to back determined 108 108
8477 56 14 minutes remaining
alright halfway point
this game isn't gonna end soon no way
okay g6 Bishop to g7 let's let's open up
this diagonal first castle get my knight
doing what am i Knight doing what now he
belongs here put pressure on this pawn
nothing was done about that I'm getting
material get my other night doing
something to my bishop wasn't doing
anything to open up this I didn't want
to do that I wanted to I wanted to go
over c8 it's a free piece okay they
resigned back determine 108 104 88 70 60
250 who all right stay focused the Alban
counter gambit not really the correct
approach I don't have to take there my
knight has a really good position here
should have secured my Knights position
with age 4
okay Punk okay now this is locked I want
Mike my knight on f4 I'm okay with
giving back that material I just are not
actually let's do this this is weakened
but they'd have a knight that could get
there or they're cool can't be so great
on that squared either could always
challenge it with Queen d2 it's probably
gonna happen soon Queen to somewhere
Queen did that beef for square pressure
on this pond this prawn has hit a bunch
of times I'm defending it though I can
defend it again there might be potential
Forks with this bv6 stuff they do this
everything is concentrated on that point
it's going down but the Queen is a not a
good leader in defending that pond I
don't even know what I want to do let me
have this pawn clamp down 17 seconds 17
seconds that pawns falling I get this
guy going here there Knight is way too
tricky way too tricky 12 seconds just
get rid of him March this pawn okay this
pond is past two gonna take here they
have back rank issues they're back rank
issues okay they still have back rank
issues
okay the knight here next six seconds
right here could with a lot faster now
thankfully just get this pond pushing
okay I think that might have been okay
there no back to Chairman I think that
might have been close to Stanley with
that last move I was going to do I don't
know if they would have had another King
move 11 minutes remaining
I'm surprised that I still have a chance
to uh to win actually with that loss
usually anyone laughs really really sets
you back but I still have an opportunity
so let's defend c6 it's castle this
isn't gonna end soon okay I have these
hanging pawns all right I have the
bishop pair let's get on this I want to
break down their dark squares so let me
get an F for there's a lot of pressure
built up on that pond I'm on their queen
they were probably looking for some
tactic there yeah but the Queen was
hanging I'm okay with giving up that
light square bishop I'm looking for made
on h2 it's happening soon thing their
King has to run they resigned back
determine 148 144 128 108 80 148 148 144
oh all right
this is a big game the exchange the
exchange Slav the most the most violent
of the openings I get in c4 in my rook
working and let's go for this break I
think it's looking good because I'm on
the rook and I'm looking at mate this is
actually turning out pretty good so far
so good but am I going to get trapped
maybe I'm gonna come back and I'm
looking for me somewhere let's give some
checks okay with some material trades
your queen can't go too far I would
actually have an intermediate move
like we get entrapped let's get this
light-square bishop out of there and
then double up on this pond right here I
want to get rid of this but I want to
watch out for me watch out for that me
rook takes here I have to watch out for
a night tricks night tricks I'm on this
pond how many times look over stuff is
looking pretty good
where are the checks I don't mind that
night I actually have a pretty good time
advantage which is just nice but I could
evaporate in a second
clean checks I'm dropping the rook back
and I have to win this ah get this
Knight out of there he's way too tricky
oh I got this Knight get rid of this
pawn
okay I snuck that one in there okay oh I
thought it was a forfeit on time I
thought that was a stalemate that final
position what they were down on time all
right that was a tough game as usual all
right I'm gonna take this cuz I don't
think that this is enough compensation
for the pond because of the tsunami of
ponds in the center I like my dark
square bishop bishop here is that gonna
be annoying I'm gonna look for stuff
against their king
actually let's get him out of here build
my center a little bit where's their
queen going it could be very cautious
I'm on each to their dark square Bishop
their dark square Bishop is gone now
this could be taken let me let me get
out of this potential attacks pile up on
this night here he's pinned I should be
looking to hit him again he's not pinned
now I'm gonna push here though so I can
open up this diagonal I want another pin
to be happening actually I shouldn't
allow that so there's a couple pins my
opponent could potentially be in clean
over here
I wanna clean trade even on the clock
he's ready to take that night that would
not have been good if the Queen moves I
have that pawn push so let's let's let's
just keep that sitting and double up on
this square okay now my dark square
Bishop is a monster
both of my bishops are monsters here
let's just keep pushing one of them is
pinned their knight is pinned I'm gonna
keep them pinned let's try to attack him
next okay let's just simplify into a one
King and pawn in game actually I don't
need my King's help let's come over here
no stalemates let's get this guy going
let's give check no matter what that's
me
there's probably a bunch of mates that I
missed 228 184 166 six minutes remaining
I don't know if I'm not catching 228
it's the guy that beat me his name's
Jerry just saying hi hi Jerry efore be
five kicked this night away so there
isn't compensation is this variation cuz
I'm okay well this is a fork now but I'm
just getting a really strong center with
this variation and I'm up a pond and I'm
up timewise developmentally just keep
things really simple get my bishop
working right here Bishop e2 I just
moved my rook make sure I have a flight
square for my king
okay I have a flight square after they
take my knight and I'm just gonna take
here next and then here back rank make
threats that these pawns going get one
of them passed my epon is gonna be
passed soon and their King is gonna try
to come over to defend against that
actually can't stop from cleaning so
easily now I could have taken that rook
also could have taken that rook mating -
okay Natan - back to term in 204 - 228
204 188 whoo five minutes remaining less
than five minutes remaining
all right c5 d5 in with tempo and the
elimination of a floor means the great
transition happens actually go from and
this wasn't a fantastic idea to do that
push I was I was silly but um you you
experienced a great Tran transition
right there you go from
equal you you surpassed equalizing and
you go right into actually having an
advantage let's kick this night away I
want to reinforce C for you jump in he
is a monster
functioning on these light squares now
my Brooke opposite their queen and oh I
could take here soon
Bishop here next why did I just drop
that pond
okay well Night Moves Night Moves are
good here on their queen and that Queen
oh they didn't they didn't take my rough
they had they could have taken my rook
and where's the main I want to get rid
of there I'm just gonna sack just take
this guy out
rook here mates very soon happening is
that okay I don't know if this is the
fastest but I'm just want to control G
to control g2 and then mate or f2 to g2
stuff as well I have this square okay
that's me
there was no it wasn't a way to escape
right there two forty eight to forty
eight to twenty four to eighteen three
minutes remaining d 4e for some gambit
which is rare rare to see me playing
gambits I don't know how good this one
is here but I'm gonna give it a shot I
don't know how great that move is either
or how I'm even deploying my pieces in
this gambit but I'm looking to attack on
the h7 square get my queen over here can
I get rid of that Knight is the big
question
the knight could play right here and
interfere with the mate threat
so I'm looking to take the knight out
and then made on each seven so they're
looking to give checkmate to me which
isn't cool
now the knight can't move so easily
because of this Bishop I'm looking to
take him out how do they defend one of
these ponds have to move and we lose the
night so you probably have to go here
and I think I'll just get my other rook
and play they're gonna move they're
really thinking this one through okay
I'm a vh7 on right now I move the
defender h7 it is back to term at 244 to
268 244 236 216 again let's try the
Sicilian Oh Smith more okay we're
turning into Benoni and I should be
going in this direction actually let's
get my knight working they should avoid
the knight exchange and they are can I
get this Knight exchange in I could and
I think that this is beneficial to me to
get that particular exchange in I want
my queen out doing something okay with
this I want my Queen out I'm hitting the
bishop I'm tied down to the defense of
this pawn which isn't great so I want to
actually do what I want to make sure I
could defend this pawn let's get this
pawn out of here keep the Queen around a
little bit that's so easy yeah and then
I'm in a very tight spot right now
actually the queen is dead that was very
helpful there Bishop still gonna play on
they're gonna take here or there get rid
of their dark square Bishop all right
they're getting that pawn I want to get
rid of their dark square Bishop even at
the cost of a pawn I'm gonna do it
winning material my queen has a bunch of
checks this is actually looking pretty
good right now the rope can't go too far
let's get a past fun run my past pun
actually I want to dislodge there there
LightSquared bishop so how am I gonna do
that they're kind of stuck with moving I
can't go move too far so I could get
this in
why did I do that actually I have a
really big lead on with time Oh
third place confetti it didn't finish i
couldnt get that last game in there
that one was sailor is 2.3 seconds left
all right good games Oh
288 246 244 216 198 156 very good Turner
alrighty